you think you can fix me Jean you are  not broken  you do read the pine there's a fragile  thing takes only the slightest tap to  tip it in the wrong direction  Charles what did you do I had to keep a  stable I protected her from the truth  there's another word for them I came  looking for answers  you feel like you don't belong here you  don't they can't begin to comprehend but  you are she's changing that's what you  didn't come here looking for answers you  came here looking for permission  [Music]  she's all right  Hey missile coming after us  Jeanne masking fault is she still our  friend  this is your default choice but world is  on the brink I'm sorry I didn't stop it  sooner you're always sorry Charles  and there's always a speech but nobody  cares they're still  don't do this  they're right to see me I've seen Havel  I'm looking at it now  [Applause]  [Music]